over the course of a film and television
career that spanned over 30 years Johnny
Depp has played more than a few strange
characters some have been part of his
bizarre collaborative history with
director Tim Burton which is seen him
become everyone from Willy Wonka to
Sweeney Todd but he's also always
marched to the beat of a different
drummer by himself though he's had a
tortured relationship with Fame Johnny
Depp is still a master of his craft and
an extremely interesting guy to boot
even after spending all these years in
the limelight there's still plenty
that's been left out of the headlines
about the enigmatic actor and musician
this is the untold truth of Johnny Depp
auspicious start there's a long-standing
Hollywood rumor that Johnny Depp first
got his start after his first wife
introduced him to her ex-boyfriend who
just so happened to be Nicolas Cage and
Depp has somewhat corroborated the story
in his own words and somebody said well
why don't you go meet an agent my agent
you know I was in the cage and you said
he'll kill me my agent and she sent me
to audition for something and I got it
caged reportedly saw something in Depp
and opened some crucial early career
doors for him soon after he was cast in
his first film role in a Nightmare on
Elm Street and with that he was
officially an actor making movie magic
thanks to projects like platoon cry-baby
21 Jump Street and Edward Scissorhands
Johnny Depp started to boast some clout
in Tinseltown in the early 90s the film
he decided to cash his chips anon was
What's Eating Gilbert Grape
so the story goes then girlfriend Winona
Ryder read Peter Hedges novel of the
same name and got Depp to read it to he
felt that was a modern-day Catcher in
the Rye and identified strongly with
Gilbert a young man trapped in a small
town and saddled with family
responsibilities it was a residue you
know it was sort of left over there from
my childhood that I connected to and you
know
with that character and with those
people depth then told director loss a
hallström about the book and the two
agreed to work on the film before there
was even a script in place hallstrum
enlisted the author hedges to work on
the script and the rest was movie
history sticking to music when Johnny
Depp first came to California he
actually didn't intend to be an actor he
was actually in a band called the kids
who'd been pretty successful around the
greater southeast death actually dropped
out of high school because of the band
and they opened for national acts like
the Talking Heads the pretenders and the
Ramones after the band split up he
turned to acting but Depp never forgot
his love for music and was in the glam
band Rock City Angels before making his
screen breakthrough depth later started
the band P with butthole surfers
frontman Gibby Haynes although they
broke up fairly quickly he remained
musically active most recently he's been
in a band called the Hollywood vampires
alongside Alice Cooper Aerosmith
guitarist Joe Perry in Guns and Roses
vets Duff McKagan and Matt Sorum the
members say they've all had brushes with
death and Depp in particular seems to
feel lucky to be part of the
collaboration kid-friendly by portraying
Captain Jack Sparrow in the Pirates of
the Caribbean series Johnny Depp got to
bring a lot of joy to children both in
and outside of the theaters he spent a
great deal of his free time suiting up
in the character costume to visit
children's hospitals and schools and the
reason for his particular fondness for
children has a little something to do
with his own experiences as a father
they're given me the gifts I was the
parent when my daughter was ill I've
known darkness in my life but that was
the darkest period ever you know of
course Jack Sparrow isn't the only
character he is embodied to bring joy to
his youngest fans in 2016 he acted in
the black gondola a micro budgeted movie
about a young man who in the wake of a
zombie apocalypse risks everything to
save the life of his companion the short
movie came together thanks to the make
of film Foundation a charity which helps
film making dreams come true for kids
and teens with serious medical problems
the film was written by and starred
Anthony Conte a 16 year old who is
stricken with Stage four adrenal
cortical cancer and deaf happily joined
in as one of the film's supporting
a-listers cinematic chameleon Johnny
Depp has tried on so many different
screen personas that
entirely possible that even he doesn't
know what he looks or sounds like
anymore even in interviews he tends to
talk with affectation 'he's that sound
like they're somewhere between great
britain boston and wonderland and he
also seems to enjoy disappearing into
his roles the last thing i want to look
like is myself yeah
i've always felt that it was important
to escape so if you ever wondered why he
tends to choose roles that make him
virtually unrecognizable it's because he
seems to prefer on-screen anonymity even
still he refuses to watch his own movies
anyway i've seen only a couple that have
had the city life was just just to check
for you know the cut or whatever to make
sure that the cut was cool getting
political in addition to making movies
and music deb has also been known to use
his platform to raise awareness for
political causes alongside several other
socially conscious artists depp
participated in the voice projects
imprisoned for art campaign in late 2016
appearing in a mug shot to shed light on
a ukrainian filmmaker serving a 20-year
jail sentence in siberia death is also
no fan of donald trump and appeared in a
Funny or Die lost movie called the art
of the deal based on the Trump book by
the same name the movie was posted the
morning Trump won the New Hampshire
primary but Depp's continued to whip out
his spot-on impressions on command well
I got a feel for him because in
sensational absolutely fabulous I told
them to build a wave in that wall I want
a sensational wall if alec baldwin ever
decides to stop impersonating the
President on Saturday Night Live it
looks like Johnny Depp could fit right
into it personal problems as much as he
might like to sink into his screen roles
in recent years Johnny Depp's personal
life has become a very publicized roller
coaster he and former wife Amber Heard
caused something of an international
incident in 2015 when they traveled to
Australia to film the latest Pirates
installment and brought along their two
Yorkshire Terriers upon arrival the
couple failed to properly declare the
animals with customs officials
mr. Dettman after either take his dogs
back to California or we're gonna have
to euthanize them they were forced to
return the smuggled animals to the
United States and heard pleaded guilty
to knowingly producing a false or
misleading document for failing to
disclose the dogs the two ended up
delivering an awkward apology video
which he was later able to laugh about I
would really like to apologize for not
smuggling my dogs that was just the
start of their problems their marriage
soon after ended in disaster as the
actress claims that he'd been abusive to
her during their relationship she also
alleged that Depp was addicted to
alcohol and other substances though
their divorce was finalized relatively
quickly Depp's days of making headlines
for all the wrong reasons were far from
over financial woes with over fifty
million dollars worth of property in one
of Hollywood's most interesting resumes
to his name it was a bit shocking to
learn that Johnny Depp has major money
problems shortly after his split from
her Depp's legal woes raged on after his
attorney and accountant informed him
that he was financially underwater the
two reportedly had to make dev
understand that his income was being
outpaced by his spending on luxuries
like art jewelry wine property and the
3.6 million dollars per year he paid his
personal staff Depp finally agreed to
sell his yacht but it was the start of a
tense communication between the three
that would end with depth firing both of
his advisers Depp went on to allege that
his former managers caused him to rack
up more than 40 million dollars in debt
and to dispose of valuable assets and
that they talked him into high interest
loans that they didn't make payments on
they responded by claiming that Depp was
irresponsible prompting legal actions on
both sides in January 2017 depth filed
suit against the Management Group for
mismanagement of his wealth and for
defrauding him out of money during the
course of their duties between 1999 and
2016 Depp claimed that the company
siphoned some twenty eight million
dollars and that they didn't pay his
taxes on time TMG countersued if all of
that wasn't bad enough he's also been
sued by his former bodyguards for unpaid
wages and unsafe work conditions thin
but ok Johnny Depp appeared in two major
films in 2017 Murder on the Orient
Express and Pirates of the Caribbean
dead
men tell no tales and lined up a few
more for 2018 including the fantastic
beasts sequel the crimes of Grindelwald
death looked mostly like his youthful
self in those films which is why fans
were shocked when an odd picture of the
actor circulated around the internet in
spring 2018 where he's posing with a fan
in Russia who can ghostly pale and
skeletally thin while deaf often
drastically alters his appearance for
films the sudden physical transformation
still proved alarming leaving fans
wondering why Depp was looking so skinny
blaming everything from drug addiction
to preparing for a movie role as it
happens it's probably for a film Depp is
set to star in a dramedy called Richard
says goodbye as a professor dying of a
terminal illness Deb obviously still has
no trouble scoring promising projects
even now working lunch I'm on a roll
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]